if I give you a piece of [ __ ] but gravy
on it yeah cut it and look at me
straight in the eye no Joey this is the
best piece of [ __ ] story that the
shitty [ __ ] you trying to tell me
what delicious French it's [ __ ]
delicious nutritious and beneficence and
I'm saying look at this remember we the
[ __ ] Brad Pitt don't smoke with me
god Brett picked I'll smoke this [ __ ]
[ __ ] we got that's right [ __ ]
yeah look let's go live how do we watch
Italy YouTube got pwned youtube.com
backseats us Julia's
as usual we open this [ __ ] up
with a bomb [ __ ] it's Sunday night
you sit there should I watch football
what yeah the churches on [ __ ] me
no matter that uncle joey's on grab that
[ __ ] bottle I'll give you two minutes
grab the bong fill up with [ __ ] water
tell mom to get the [ __ ] out for ten
minutes and we're going deep tonight you
understand me we got all the you time
you see what this is right here this is
a strip of the [ __ ] and look at this
autograph from England they sent it this
is the acid that [ __ ] [ __ ] Barrett
did and left the [ __ ] Pink Floyd
we're doing it tonight they'll autograph
you like when you go on eBay and they
sign some look at that
there's the Syd Barrett acid look at
this [ __ ] we got stars of death - coming
back tomorrow so you know what just cuz
you ain't [ __ ] playing your game
we're doing our thing edibles from the
heart cookie these things don't kill you
we got one we got to we got three we got
four we got five we got six and never
[ __ ] ends here this one I always like
a bad habit here it's time for me to do
a bomb hold on I gotta get this [ __ ]
thing ready like me now [ __ ]
we got made the shed on 1972 three
Rolling Stones of the album I gotta
[ __ ] $8 the other day look at this
look at this look at this look at this
how much was it [ __ ] $8.99 this is
like the greatest is pseudo let me tell
you what's on this [ __ ] out right here
explain to these [ __ ] what's on
this out here
you got brown sugar tumbling dice happy
dance little sister dance and [ __ ]
wild waters that's what one side let me
hit you with the other side Angie [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's only rock and roll and rip
this [ __ ] joint oh are you kidding me
a one you need [ __ ] with a hit of acid
to listen to this [ __ ] masterpiece
understand you need acid but listen to
this [ __ ] masterpiece I also got two
other classics from you yet crisis
classics Oh God [ __ ] Mombasa the
police are you kidding me or what
what is this goal regarded it works
whatever the [ __ ] yeah I'm not good at
French [ __ ] name a monster this
is where this drummers shine right here
no no but this is this is the one with
the ring oh yeah I'll be wrapped around
your finger
this has synchronicity this has although
it doesn't have ghosts from the machine
oh [ __ ] ghost in the machine that's the
next one
[ __ ] you people think I've been [ __ ]
around all weekend and going to farmers
markets drinking Perrier warm like what
are you [ __ ] mu P ops I'm out here
bang I went to the store I smoked reefer
and went deep in the murky waters of the
underworld to get some [ __ ] said what
have you done huh what have you done
with your [ __ ] weekend your health
has I took the baby to soccer
I said McDonald's I went to go to a
soccer ball we had a good party I don't
[ __ ] around here you understand me I
gotta get some water milk and getting
all parts and excited from evening
all weekend go hunt he's been a training
he's like one of four thousand men's and
training flavor the only flavor his
edibles is depth okay
that look at these two look at these two
[ __ ] nuggets look at this look at
this beauty right here look at the size
of this monster coming at you and look
at this [ __ ] cool pyaar kyun look at
this one
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] was the [ __ ]
the record player Lee oh [ __ ]
just when you thought the safe [ __ ] up
here high shoes your dress on time dance
oh [ __ ] dance little sister
- yo here we go she passed Sammy oh [ __ ]
[Music]
- dance little sister - well should we
open up with the sit first what's one
with some edibles really think it's time
for some edibles we say check this out
push [ __ ] tomorrow the stars
make a comeback but for tonight we gotta
go with the push monsters in oh that
boat this is liquid heroin right here
these things if you haven't seen the
devil this is the [ __ ] that'll make you
take you to his doorstep so if you wanna
knock on the door
that's up to you you don't say right or
wrong Lisa and this [ __ ] citizen to
put us over the top lately it's gonna be
mr. Floyd Lee will be awake come on
may I go right I can take two it's acid
and be snoring an hour later how [ __ ]
[ __ ] is too high Oh
lianna sit Marilyn turn the lights out
this [ __ ] [ __ ] same thing
[Music]
oh [ __ ] let's do one more pong get out
of respect for the soldiers that are not
real today one of my friends and Sunday
it's the Lord's Day or souls days coming
up you gotta think of the soldiers
laying around from time to time and do a
bong hit for them for the [ __ ]
soldiers here we go concept
[Music]
that's not a bonnet I don't know what
the [ __ ] is this is that wish three for
the month to smoke [ __ ] here's
the distant way to dodge the smoke last
night after they lost their like this is
the leap this month before they went to
the pizza maybe let we left some last
week
[ __ ] 18 [ __ ] you III slight you
ate three pizzas [ __ ] three
slices look at this will go right off
the bat will be tonight squalls anxiety
you understand me
and they're nice and fresh take a little
hard you know I gave to you the same
soul next [ __ ] here look at these
cubes it's a fright you look at it oh go
on deeply you would open up with 600
right off the bat ahead asses if that
don't take you down I don't know what
the [ __ ] will wait to jump
[Music]
we don't mean one of the time just a
[ __ ] can eat the Beatles all I want
contract
yummy for your [ __ ] tummy they come
for spices just to let you know how
strongly smoked something love now then
I get a little sentimental when I'm for
you know wild horses wouldn't drag me oh
[ __ ]
which the Mexican ice cream man that
[ __ ] bad to the bone he's got
ice cream shoes paint materials a hammer
everything [ __ ] truck don't come now
at 6:00 and he'll come back to live in
there you're sitting your liberal the
minute you hear he don't give a [ __ ]
kids are running out there with no
curfew bunch of little orphans it's easy
to do just like that why the [ __ ] [ __ ]
around with yourself listen people I'm a
[ __ ] antique compared to you
[ __ ] and if I could add all over
again I would hate these every [ __ ]
day since I was 3 or whatever the
Sabbath 3
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
jesus [ __ ] christ
oh that's a family portrait right there
if I ever saw one there's a three
flowers oh my god I love seeing you guys
I've missed you since last Wednesday
[Music]
that's why we got lift tonight
Oh seesaw and water and helix oh [ __ ]
good take you away understand buoy what
did the [ __ ] who spiked at least his
leash tons of women switch would have
beened away so please ready for market
when you sat there leave sitting there
go what the [ __ ] is being sitting in my
chair it's all nice to see you
[ __ ] on a Sunday on the wards
there you readily say it almost this
weed has your name and I walked into the
[ __ ] the one I Jews house today
you said on Lee's favorite [ __ ]
Reaper tonight oh [ __ ] who loves you
wanna make that second huh nobody wait
what's the story with the [ __ ] beans
always a further tonight the guys from
Watergate Watergate
Lee I got people here waiting on you you
swallow the [ __ ] thing enough to chew
is just gonna shot like a good [ __ ] come
on wait that's not that light I just
tossed it back like a clam you'll be the
clamp
look at look at this one admission look
at this one four years of college
miss Elson he's still pushing stuff to
make me believe that time was - rondalee
oh yes beauty is a [ __ ] whilst Emily if
we get the blood going
oh [ __ ] sometimes yeah sometimes you got
to break y'all record you know so
sometimes you got to break your own
record [ __ ] that I'm telling you
look at this [ __ ] beauty Wow
[Music]
look at my little that's what the
weekends are for training I won't let
the plain Monday through Friday training
training day every day is training day
[ __ ] I wish I look like even huh
is that yellow piece of [ __ ] you
understand
look at that bonehead now keep going
stay in there stay in there stay in
there it's the slow tac of death
they you know there you go like a strobe
yeah that's why I got trained every day
people don't care what they tell you
you're no credit ain't no credit be a
[ __ ] slept Sunday Night Football
for my Sunday like [ __ ] terror here
at the podcast of death isn't the last
[ __ ] Romania there's a great Jam if
you're too young to know this Jam look
it up
it's called Angie by the Rolling Stones
Mick Jagger [ __ ] drops on this
[Music]
un-fuckin'-believable to cry about hi
Jen I still love you unbelievable hot
breakfast always
[Music]
you don't down little we do on a Sunday
night I'm happy you join us whether you
guys were here and that is what we be
doing with being a [ __ ] room
somewhere the door Oh didn't listen to
music on his vinyl some water are we
losing their minds you lazy general
which is doing what everybody else does
and nobody wants to show you we don't
give a [ __ ] here I got one for the
Greymon a banana piece they got worried
about [ __ ] gives up [ __ ] have a good
time enjoy your life you [ __ ] write
your goals 322 [ __ ] pushes very
important and if you're an 18 get off
this [ __ ] line like that I don't need
you [ __ ] these little dumb
pedophile looking for us
[Music]
I love it I love seeing you
[ __ ] now it's the moment you've
been waiting for the Syd Barrett war
relaxes you what are you gonna do how
you gonna act when you get there what's
the sticker on your shell for me Angie
Angie's it's time for some [ __ ]
perennial all right let's do this
[ __ ] for any of these buds are
delicious
we got a lot to talk about tonight yeah
lot to talk about
that's it you're gonna vote next week
we'll gives a [ __ ] you already made up
your decision not one more tape a trunk
we grab as some chicks [ __ ] your
[ __ ] Luisa Benghazi [ __ ] doing
something the Benghazi [ __ ] there you
go no st. Lazzaro coming up December
17th [ __ ] you get it together
look at this thing again look at this
media
[Music]
Timmy Holloway gave us that thing for
the [ __ ] studio don't tell me how the
Secaucus New Jersey to camp in Turkey on
the front
Timmy Julian can be seen as a [ __ ]
mad as like any tendency Timmy Timmy
Timmy who gives a [ __ ] Sam look at that
Lee with how brace and when fingers like
gold this is liquid [ __ ] zone
understanding 600 milligrams in who's
better you lease I am nobody
when you finish your dinner happy you
tapped in your little lacox laughter
[Music]
[Applause]
but I imagine dinner with the family is
everything on the Lord's Day
everywhere I look I see your eyes
[Music]
there ain't no warm and that comes close
to you are you [ __ ] kidding me
there ain't a woman that comes close to
you who the [ __ ] says that type of stuff
I in jail
[Music]
ain't it good to be alive you with your
uncle Joey tonight you could be out
there wasting [ __ ] time
there's the Man of Steel look at him
[ __ ] doing bonsai they gonna
understand that's my boy right there
look at the fly zhu li i li dog his eyes
already [ __ ] red oshare we go because
mine don't get red no more they stopped
they gave up and [ __ ] 93 I did a
[ __ ] bunch of - I was a bowler
here we go I can't understand it oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm gonna clean this [ __ ] up how you
like me now [ __ ] that yeah when you
call my name oh [ __ ] would you stop with
the game oh [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] fan of
bana bana bana bana
[Music]
alright are you [ __ ] nuts and you
thought it was gonna be a boring evening
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
sometimes that sexy huh move like a stud
like what
[Music]
they're going they're going these
[ __ ]
[Music]
this is too much this is too much this
[ __ ] Jam I put this on like eight
times the other it drives you they have
instead own stop block the whole song
micktaylor and keep Richards just like a
[ __ ] monster door here I'm hungry
can't you be the reason
ready for another bottle of dope yeah
when you call my name oh [ __ ] oh my god
listen to ish here we go the sax jesus
[ __ ] christ
this will never happen again [ __ ]
ever
this is heroin mixed with [ __ ] talent
mixed with [ __ ] passion are you
kidding me
this is too much [ __ ] I don't know
what you're thinking about but next time
you think you'd do something bad to the
bone listen for this [ __ ] Jam that'll
stop
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
whistling can't walk on one leg Oh Sam
[Music]
look at that
that's [ __ ] beauty right there loose
ad you look right into the camera said
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you understand me
you tap out when the eyes look like that
I see clear no veins busted
they just tapped out it's a joke we're
not going for this golf ball especially
when Keith britches on that [ __ ] to you
here we go keep what
this is too much [ __ ] break up
the syringe with the goat here we go we
kick the mule oh [ __ ] I said listen to
this [ __ ] this is a car slept with
Sunday night the church will see you in
10 minutes this is as good as it gets in
your [ __ ] in the world especially when
the luckiest day you had was a day your
dog got run over by a car [ __ ] Lucky's
here we go to church you too dot see
slot [ __ ] math flavor just wait for
the tweet from Lee I'll retweet it and
you guys are ready to rock all right
stay black uncle Joey loves you thank
you for joining us
oh [ __ ] I almost forgot we didn't take
off Heather's sick
[Music]
in my heart
no but the spice oh [ __ ] yeah go deep
sometimes I put the goggles like I'm
saying
[Music]
because he just massively well he's just
Master Maynard
[Music]
like this
[Music]
who loves you more than me [ __ ] up
there's nobody Jesus gave you his blood
I do a head and said what the [ __ ] he's
getting sick on the [ __ ] alright
[ __ ] we'll see you in 10 minutes
be there or be square okay and remember
don't sample join all of you all right
that's the last thing when I you think
I'd love to stay black